hello everyone and welcome to yet
another game you've all requested were
still at round two well round two and on
day two of the st. Louis rapid and blitz
event this is the rapid section it's
Magnus cross and good white pieces
against Levin Aragon the leader after
day one and well there's no mystery boy
will requested this game it's a very
nice game so let's just dive straight
into it Magnus just lost his game
against Fabiana Cora wanna
in the previous round so let's see how
he bounces back he opens with d4 with
Knight to f6 by 1192 f3 with d5 and now
not going for some c4 action but rather
Bishop to F for Magnus goes for the
London system with east six by 11 and
now III with Bishop to b6 and Magnus
retreats with Bishop to g3 it is
possible to play some like 92 and allow
blacks to capture a knife or to double
your F pawns then you will have an icy 5
outpost for your knight but at the
highest level Bishop to g3 is the main
line so this is what's crossing place
with castles by 11 Knight bTW - and now
b6 c5 is the main line 11 ops for b6 so
we have C 3 by Carlsen gosh up to b7 t
NK - in the light square bishop and now
Bishop to d3 and I Square to develop
your light square Bishop Queen to c2 is
coming from where you will pressure h7
and here we have Knight B to d7 94 right
away is possible but 11 wants to keep
his options open so first night here
maybe 94 was the idea on the next move
so the other night can take his DF 6
square but as cousin goes Quinta C - now
the e4 square is nicely covered by white
and here is a very funny moment well not
in this game here 11 captured on g3
because he wants to play c5 and you
cannot play c5 as your bishop here on d6
sorry about that the the coloring on my
laptop is impossible you can't play c5
as the bishop on d6 will be hanging but
there actually is one game in the
database where c5 was played in this
position Y just played capture some b6
and that's it so it's you know amazing
what you can find in the database when
you're looking
Bishop captures ng3 of course Levin will
not play c5 with H captors and g3 now
Magnus gets the semi open H file for his
rook and h6 of course now the h7 phone
was pressured with rook to h4 Magnus
losing his previous game to Fabiano now
really wants to get back into the game
so a very nice rook lift again covering
the e4 square and maybe he can use it
for attack later on maybe he may be he's
gonna Castle queenside bring the other
rook over to h1 maybe even King he too
is an idea who knows what can happen
with c5 by 11 and now Knight to e5 with
rook to c8 now developing the rook on a
nice C file that the White Queen
occupies and f4 now strengthening the
knight on e5 with x86 by 11 and now a
for preventing b5 and now finally seek
after sandy for as the C pawn is pinned
weave he captures on d4 by Magnus and
the now Knight captures on e5 with F
captures on e5 and now Knight back to d7
so Magnus was able to clear some
defenses in front of Iranians King and
now Knight to f3 and now a lot of ideas
are possible you could Castle queenside
you could play some like King f2 and
then bring the rook over to h1 there are
a lot of ways you can play this but one
thing is for sure
Magnus King is still in the center and
Levin wants to open up the position so
f6 Magnus captures with eek a person f6
Queen captures on f6 and now rook to f4
just attacking 11th Queen Queen back to
e7 and now Bishop to h7 check Magnus
wants 11 scheme to go to h8 now he has
ideas of night h4 followed by Knight g6
check and winning the Queen there are a
lot of lights lights were weaknesses
around the black King but that
unfortunately doesn't work for Magnus
here Magnus says do good save options
that's either to Castle queenside or
just the Tradeworks rock characters and
I fade but Magnus goes for Knights to h4
nonetheless and here 11 says oh no you
don't hear 11 punishes Magnus's
insolence and well feel free to pause
the video and you're welcome to try and
find what what Lacan do too
to punish white in this position while
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are about to beat
the world champion well for the second
round in a row and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show here 11:00
played rook captures on f4 and now
Magnus doesn't have a choice here he has
to go for a night to g6 check and trap
the Queen well [ __ ] the Queen but it
doesn't work here Magnus playing IG 6
check with King captures on h7 Knight
captures on e7 with a discovered check
from here but here is the move Magnus
most likely missed rook to e4 it blocks
check and delivers checked cross and
sking and the problem is if you move the
King and this is the whole point of the
of the Queen sacrifice for example if
you give to rook e8 wins the night this
is what you had to see if you found
route captures an f4 if you didn't then
well you have a it was a good idea but
you also have to calculate everything so
here all of the squares that the knight
can go to are covered there we go the
knight cannot go to any of these squares
the King covers g6 and the rook broken
King and well rook and Bishop covered
the the back rank and the knight is
trapped whatever you play let's say
Brooke you won he was gonna go rook
captures on e7 the night is lost and
let's say trade here can happen but then
you have a bishop a knight and a look
for the Queen which is in itself really
terrible but not only that xi has a
protected pass pawn on e4 and on top of
that his King is very well protected by
the pawns
so this is unplayable by white after
rook to e4 check Magnus saw that that if
he plays King to have to the game is
over he decided to go for Queen captures
on e4 he gave back the Queen and he will
recapture the rook on c8 we have D
captures on e4 Knight captures on c8
with Bishop captures on c8 and now both
players have six points Magnus has a
rock but Levin has a bishop and the
knight so of course a bishop and the
night are better than a rook but who
knows you know the game is still young
anything can happen with
for my Magnus and now kink the g6 Levin
now wants to get his king in the center
of the board
we have c4 and king to f7 and here
Magnus plays b5 which is we're gonna
talk a bit more about this b5 move at
the end of the game but it is very
important especially for for how Magnus
was feeling at the moment for example if
a 5 then captures captures then you have
this rook controlling the 5th rank and
you have these nice pawns controlling
all of the squares in front of them and
you keep the bishop and the night at
base so you're still playing this game
however after this b5 move across an 11
played a 5 creating more weaknesses we
have D captures on e5 and now a 5
completely blocking across and spawn
structure on the Queen side now he's
gonna get the King in there capture on
e5 and then he's gonna go deal with the
Queen side points with rook to d1 by
Carlsen and now Knight captures on e5
with rook to d4 and now not even
bothering with Bishop to a5 to guard the
d4 pawn but rather Bishop to e6 by 11
with rook captures on e4 and now Knight
captures on c4 we have team T to cross
and starts improving the position of his
own King and now Knight to d6 attacking
the rook rook to f4 check King to e7 and
now King to d3
but here 11 just played Knight to the
night to b7 and yes it was in this
position I'll move 35 that magnus
carlsen resigned the game as there was
nothing more to do here next whatever
Magnus plays let's say King before 95 is
coming attacking the pawn and if King c3
so the rogue defends the phone but
should be three you're now gonna gobble
up the pawns here start pushing the
points on the King side there's nothing
nothing white can do here across the
nose this and of course he resigned and
a well fought game and the world
deserved the victory 411 are down in in
this matchup against Magnus Carlsen so
this is what I mentioned and the point
is that at the end of the game 11 had
about two minutes on the clock Magnus
had almost 10 minutes 9 minutes
something so it's a very strange for
example if Magnus played this game you
know to equally without missing anything
without wondering and it would
missing that idea of rook captures an F
for most likely in that position where
he played a five he might you know he
might find B Phi with so so much time on
the clock as you know he's a he's a very
good endgame player but here I think it
was more of a case that he lost the
Fabiana in the previous from now he miss
rook captures an f4 and he just gave up
on the game altogether and you know with
that kind of mindset it's more than
enough for for lemon to clinch a full
point but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it as a lot we have
requested it it's well it's 35 moves but
I do consider it to be a miniature as
after rook captures on f4 with perfectly
it's basically a game but with perfect
play that's not always the case
but yeah I would like to think I would
like to thank mark Sutherland Jessie
Bertram and Leo stone hawai for
contributing to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think over watching and I will see you
soon are continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
suggestions which are always lovely such
as this one and when I returned home to
my hometown
continuing the Capablanca saga so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day